we recently asked the members of the
BuzzFeed community to share the most
inappropriate thing their kids have ever
done these are their stories
Tracy writes we were getting ready to
leave a birthday party and went up to
the mother of the birthday child to
thank her for inviting us my
two-year-old son slapped her butt and
said thanks for the cake babe that's how
his father thanks me for dinner and
apparently he thought it was just how
you thank people for food that's not how
you think we pour food I'll get you
fired from your job real quick kid
surprise your dad still has a job with
that kind of attitude
Megan writes after my son learned what
made boys and girls different he started
introducing himself to random people
thusly hi I'm John and I do not have a
vagina Oh John that's cute minsun writes
my three-year-old son broke free from me
in the crowded shopping mall yelling
ball when I finally shoved through the
crowds of fountains he had pried a
tennis ball often actually man's a
walker and was engaged in an intense
tug-of-war over the remaining one while
on hookers gates I hastily pride my son
away from him the Walker apologized
profusely and replaced the tennis balls
oh that's so cute too I mean he's the
older guys fine it's fine yeah I mean
I've I was ethereal I'll do that too
crystal writes when my three year old
had a scrape near his penis he asked
everyone who passed us if they wanted to
see his boo boo and started pulling down
his pants
crystal get your three role together
Frank writes when my son was three he
liked to collect acorns in a plastic bag
and carry them around with him we were
in a store when a lady noticed the bag
of acorns and asked him what it was he
yelled out it's my nutsack clever play
on words Frank's son Dan writes my
two-year-old decided to tickle a
stranger's toes in the next bathroom
stop
Tara writes we were at my
mother-in-law's house for dinner when my
four year old son s is very quiet and
reserved grandfather grandpa what color
is your butthole he then proceeded to
bend over spread his cheeks in s Grampy
what color is mine okay well that's
really psychotic but good for them
Betsy writes we are having dinner at my
husband's boss's house when my four year
old told the boss's wife that Isaac
him at school I said did you make up
with Isaac and he said [ __ ] Isaac I'm
pretty sure we're never going back yeah
[ __ ] Isaac
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]